why are we always getting involved in
everyone else's trouble
because we're the freaking Guardians of
the Galaxy
in one week crank up the volume for The
Summer's biggest event I'm grouped
you're all just making up stuff that
he's saying right no
I said
metaphor
if this is the end might as well have a
little fun huh
Guardians of the Galaxy is laugh out
loud funny
a crazy adventure exactly and the best
Marvel movie since end game you left out
some important information but that is
the gist of it
accordions of the Galaxy Vol 3.
I was screaming at something scary
behind you not you you look really cool
thank you great pt-13 you make Fair get
tickets now